[Music]
hey
here we are once again we're here
[Laughter]
went the wrong way all right yeah what
are you doing i get all backwards people
i do too
i thought it was just me because i was
dumb like my brain doesn't work right
i always do [ __ ] the wrong way like
around us move the wrong way
yeah yeah so uh we're trying to get a
little backed up we recovered
from uh the show last night yeah i
didn't get too [ __ ] up i mean i was
[ __ ] i did but it was a fun show
anyway
because like i said it was a fun topic i
know at the end i nearly whipped my
[ __ ] dick out
wait did you i don't remember no i did i
just threatened
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah okay i just
remembered right before
yeah that's right
that was a good shirt wasn't i was just
playing around
yeah of course yeah jen is laughing at
all oh yeah that was very funny
that for a second i thought you might
actually do it no [ __ ] but
get the show banned yeah you probably
would well at least you'd get
demonetized probably yeah get
demonetized this [ __ ] would become a
porn channel
well wow yeah damn what's happening in
my stream that shit's [ __ ] up
oh you [ __ ] up yeah yeah you did you
broke that [ __ ] down go back in there
and try to get well it doesn't it looks
like it's still going on here and nobody
else is complaining
not [ __ ] look at that [ __ ] oh my [ __ ]
does this
my my tablet sometimes for some reason
gets confused over streaming
um youtube if i do it more than once
a day without restarting it i got to
[ __ ] restart it
although yeah my computer is kind of
like that too because
i have to restart it like several times
a day because it just goes
yeah yeah it starts doing that yeah so
uh
what just it starts losing its
connection to to uh
to youtube just youtube yeah everything
else that'll it'll be it'll work fine
yeah that's just kind of weird all right
yeah we saw a movie uh
yeah amazingly i was still even though i
was still kind of
kind of drunk last night but i was like
well it's not that late and i still need
to
watch a movie to review tomorrow and
shutter just added a new one
so i said i'll watch it and i actually
do uh remember most of it
now this movie is called scare me now if
you will remember i don't remember maybe
it was like a month or two ago
probably longer we reviewed another
movie that we found on toby
that was also called scare me and it was
an anthology
it was kind of like a cheaper like kind
of a cheap movie and i
said when we reviewed that that they're
like the confusing thing is that two
movies called scare me came out almost
exactly the same time
and i've even seen like cover art like
dvd cover or blu-ray cover art
for this movie like that looks like
designed like that movie but with
pictures from this movie
so i think people are like confusing the
two movies but it's two completely
different movies
so this movie which shutter just added i
think it said shutter original i don't
know if that's the case or not because i
think it
premiered at sundance um but yeah so i
guess like shutter just purchased it and
they just put it up like a couple of
days ago
this one is not technically not really
an anthology um
it's actually kind of more a comedy i
would say
i don't even know it's got horror
elements and it's like got a scary story
element but it's like way more
uh a comedy than a horror movie yeah and
not
really a zany comedy that i kind of
enjoy it's it's like the evil dead type
it's it's kind of psychological in in a
way
i don't know it's just kind of
newfangled that's a newfangled type
story
i wasn't really into it yeah
i'm becoming more and more of a [ __ ]
old man you are
getting
no i just i you know like i said a lot
of times watching a movie you have to be
in a certain mindset
yeah i mean and uh this one i wasn't in
a proper mindset
for it or i just or i wouldn't have
liked it anyway i don't know
you might not have too many i i didn't
love it but um
it did make me laugh out loud a few
times but like i said don't go into it
expecting it to be like scary or being
it
or even to be gory or like a horror
movie or anything it's like a comedy
first and foremost
and it's basically just like a two or
three person
uh you know ensemble and
bass so basically what the premise is
is that there is a guy named
uh fred now he is actually played by the
director of this movie this is the first
movie he's directed
so he is um i guess like his wife has
left him or he's like having some
personal problems he's like an aspiring
novelist aspiring actor whatever so i
guess he gets like an airbnb
cabin like out in the middle of nowhere
so he can like work on his
novel that he's writing which is kind of
like a werewolf story or something like
that
and uh so he goes up there and very
shortly after arriving
he discovers that the cabin very near
his
is occupied by another writer
named fanny who is actually like a very
well-regarded
horror writer like she's quite famous
and he hasn't read her book but he has
heard of her
so they decide like i guess there's like
a snowstorm
and she is over at his house because
they're hanging out or talking
and they decide that they're going to
tell each other scary stories
like until the power comes back on right
so basically the whole entire movie
is them telling scary stories to one
another and just like
acting them out like with sound effects
and stuff like that so it's basically
it's in one room
it's kind of like it struck me very much
as like a stage play you could do this
as a stage play very very easy probably
what it was
it probably started out as that yeah so
so know that going in like it's
basically the whole thing is set in this
one cabin
and it's just them telling stories
foreign and they do the voices
and they're all like act you know what i
mean like if they were acting at a stage
play
so pretty much the whole thing is like
that at one point like
um a pizza guy shows up named carlo and
he kind of gets involved too because he
really likes scary stories and he knows
who she is
so they kind of get him in on the fun
and they're like telling each other
stories and stuff
and then like kind of as it goes on like
toward the end
you kind of get more into like some
character stuff like with him and her
and like you know his him coming to
terms with his resentment of her because
she's successful and he's not successful
and all this other kind of stuff too
so like i said it's it's um
i can see how most people would find
it off-putting but
because it is very meta it is very like
wink wink it is very clever
um they even referenced udahagen in
there which i thought was
that made me laugh but you know what i
mean but i know that is so it's like
i was like oh nice okay but if you don't
really like that kind of um
that real it's it's teeters on being
pretentious or precious a little bit
like people that are like cleverer than
you know too clever for their own good
kind of thing yeah but so a lit it kind
of annoyed me a little bit
but on the other hand like some of it
i've thought was really funny
i don't think i would recommend it to
anybody
i would no i'm just no that's not what i
meant to just anybody was what i meant
to say
i wouldn't recommend it to just anybody
i would definitely probably recommend it
if you like
um you know stage play if you like
theatrical stuff or if you're a writer
yourself
um you might dig it more because you'll
kind of get like all the real clever
like barbs and [ __ ] like that
and as i said there's no not really any
gore there's nothing like that it's just
kind of like
two people in a cabin telling like
acting out stories
to one another so if that sounds like
you would like it if it sounds like
you're
that sounds like something you would
hate you probably will hate it it would
have been a lot better as a stage play
yeah i i feel like that's kind of like
what was that one movie that uh
shutter had a confessional yeah that i
think was
um kind of done like a stage play too
because everything was like inside these
confessional boots i liked that but
the problem is with the stage play
concept is that
theater is not a big thing nationwide
not everywhere not every location in the
us has a [ __ ]
yeah decent theater and there's this in
the theater scene so if you're writing
plays
you know what i mean it's in your
interest to [ __ ] have a small movie
then at least people will see it
yeah because if you go on tour or some
kind of play a chance arnold you see it
that's what i mean so i can understand
people that are more into like doing
live theater
like that better um really that really
does seem like the best way to get
as many people to see your [ __ ] as
possible is like make it into a make it
into a movie
even though you know you do kind of
complain about like i think you were
complaining about that movie
confessional like oh that would have
been worked better as the stage play
but like i said if it was a stage play
nobody would have nobody would have seen
it
and uh you know since they made it into
a movie it's on shutter and probably
you know hundreds of thousands or a
million people might have seen it which
is a lot better than doing a stage play
that's for sure true but yeah so
this um you know i i liked it it was
fine it had some like really funny
moments i liked the end
uh stay till after like some of the
credits go because i almost missed it
because the credits came on i was like
oh i gotta pee and so like i ran to the
bathroom
and then tom's like hey hey you're
missing this like scene here at the end
and i was like oh i'm kind of glad that
i saw that scene because that kind of
like gave me a little chuckle
because it was kind of like a call back
to the beginning which i liked one we
saw recently that i think that that kind
of stuck
with me was that napoleon dynamite i had
never seen that
yeah sophie that was sophie
well i had seen it before like a long
time ago but kind of reminded me of a
more
friendly version of uh of uh
art of self-defense kind of had that
same tone same kind of goofy character
yeah in it you know look look if you
guys haven't seen napoleon dynamite see
that [ __ ] i kind of feel like
everybody's probably seen it at this
point
except for you i mean it's it's kind of
like seinfeld where it's like a movie
about nothing there isn't any really
[ __ ] happens but it's just like normal
[ __ ] it's just these characters and the
way they interact it's just it's like a
slice of life
crazy [ __ ] sort of story and that
wedding at the end where he [ __ ]
comes up on that horse
and his brother marries that [ __ ]
black dude and her [ __ ] brother is
like [ __ ]
embarrassed as [ __ ] but she she's
marrying this crazy ass [ __ ] white
dude it's [ __ ]
hilarious [ __ ] hilarious [ __ ]
movie man well like i said there's a
reason
i want to own that one there's a reason
that movie like became like
a cultural yeah milestone i'm gonna put
that one right next to
i saw so many [ __ ] jokes and memes
about that one at first yeah it was
really funny
and uh trying to see what else is going
on oh yeah to do the show i got jenny
had to interrupt me because i got that
star wars squadron game
yeah he just got that he's very excited
so i had to go in there
i went in there like 20 minutes before
and i said we're going on 20 minutes oh
yeah i forgot about that and he was
playing the game and then like the time
goes time
goes and then it's like two minutes till
and i have to run in there and be like
do you know what time it is
i'm flying that [ __ ] i'm constantly
nagging i like flight games
but i wish i had real controls because
the the axis control where you roll on
your axis
it's on the same joystick as your
throttle
so you get [ __ ] confused you know i
would definitely get confused yeah i
would be in there for like a second and
then i would hit it up yeah
i want to set it up for real flight
simulation where your feet control the
roll
and you got a single joystick and then
your right hand controls the throttle
i like the little motion a lot better
[Laughter]
i want to do a virtual reality with the
[ __ ] helmet on so i can look
inside the cockpit that would probably
be easier oh it'd be a lot easier
because you're doing [ __ ] like [ __ ]
hitting your boost speed and cutting
power and then sliding
through space turning the ship sideways
or backwards
it's [ __ ] pretty cool so it's like
[ __ ] you you could you know it's like
[ __ ] i could do on a motorcycle kind of
yeah
but i don't have the right controls i'm
an old man i don't have that damn
finger dexterity to these kids you know
what i mean
we grew up with joysticks but there's
there's just no comparison to real
controls like inside a vehicle
yeah you know what i mean where the
controls are so far apart there's no way
to make any mistakes you know you don't
need fine motor control
because that's the first thing that goes
when you're panicking when you're
fighting something
or trying to win a race yeah yeah
fourth drawer down says doesn't napoleon
buy a time machine at one point that was
actually my favorite part yeah he buys a
time machine
i like the [ __ ] that wasn't napoleon
that was napoleon's uncle his uncle
bought the time machine it didn't work
yeah wouldn't it have been funnier if it
had worked um
show them my show my uh new game reach
over there again
this is not quite for sale yet because i
still need to make like [ __ ] for the uh
what you call it for the website but
this is the proof copy
of my newest one it's called boosting
botticelli it's an art theft
game yeah it's all sophisticated it's so
sophisticated that's all
you're ridiculous i'm not ridiculous yes
you are
yeah it's mostly it's mostly a card game
so there's the cards there
but it comes with like little auction
pads and stuff like that because you can
like
and there's like fakes in there and all
kind of [ __ ] like that that's fun
um this probably like they wouldn't let
me put it in a smaller box
that's the thing about game crafter is
that
standard size boxes well they have so
many boxes
and like then once you go in and you um
put in all your components
like because i had picked like a much
smaller box for that and then they were
like oh your shit's not gonna fit in
that box and i'm like really are you
sure that it's not going to fit in my
box
i think they always err on the side of
like put everything in a bigger box
you know because because i feel like
those components probably could have fit
in a smaller one but you know whatever
i i don't mind what's out of the box
yeah if you guys haven't noticed i have
what
sophie's in the comments in there i have
what sophie calls
my movie director glasses she says i'll
be coming yeah you look a little bit
like george romero
if they were bigger become like a movie
director or i kind of thought maybe it
was like the uh that dude from sicario
yeah from that movie yeah he had glasses
what was the name of that game it's
called boosting botticelli
yeah and i'm gonna [ __ ] direct a
movie goddammit
yeah cut you
[Laughter]
you want like a little like like a
little stick with the thingy on it yeah
like baby
pants put a beanie on well it's not a
baby beret a beret
a baby has a helicopter yeah yeah the
helicopter
yeah put a [ __ ] birdie
[Laughter]
what'll it say on the back of your like
director's chair [ __ ]
that's yeah
at least people know what they're
getting into
we'll let you know what it is you wanted
some [ __ ] sophisticated [ __ ] you want
me to say something sophisticated and
deep i would
not so now i would say [ __ ] on the
back no i was that's
that's about what i was expecting you to
say that's why i asked you
[ __ ] something like that right
all right oh yes 60s michael caine
glasses yeah that's right
that's what they remind me 60s michael
caine glasses
three drinks into it there you go three
drinks three jenks into the journey of
whipping your ass
because michael kane when he gets too
drunk he [ __ ] whips your ass or his
hand comes off and kills you
yeah his hand his hand comes off and
then punches and then punches jaws
yeah yeah the shark not not the human
jaw
but yeah there's goes go see uh he was
in part four right jaw is part four
i don't know was he yeah i'm pretty i
didn't see that one
it was awful but i've only seen jaws
part one
come on you haven't seen part three like
the terrible three i gotta figure out a
way to impersonate michael k
you look you look at the camera and then
you look
you look and then you look and then you
look and you talk and you look
well watch some of his like movies from
the 60s and then get you can get that
impression down man
yeah i gotta [ __ ] study him you can
you can be him for halloween you still
have time to like figure that [ __ ] out
get a perm get a perm [ __ ]
dye my hair [ __ ] blunt now let's get
a wig it was gonna take
easier to get don't get a perm yeah i'll
dress up as michael kane for one of the
shows
we should well with the halloween show
halloween i mean because halloween is on
a saturday and our show is on a saturday
so with that [ __ ] british accent yeah
that'd be oh my god that'd be hilarious
you could even get like some kind of
[ __ ] up looking teeth because his
teeth are kind of yeah
yeah yeah yeah like austin powers teeth
yeah it's you that
they have those like uh at spirit
halloween you're being [ __ ] mean he
did kind of have some [ __ ]
no they're not yeah it's like that's a
bad teeth yeah just kind of [ __ ]
i said they don't they dodged they're
interesting yeah he had dodgy teeth
they're interesting too they're
distinctive teeth how about that yeah
but yeah um yeah somebody said i love
his horror movie the hand we actually
reviewed that a while back
i really really liked that movie too
that movie i saw when i was a kid and it
like
creeped me the [ __ ] out because i always
had like a weird
uh well i guess it's not a weird fear
but like um kind of an irrational fear
of having like limbs
removed yeah tila's in there saying she
loved the hand i thought that's what i
just said
yeah yeah she said oh you oh she you
yeah
sometimes he doesn't listen no i was
zoned out i'll read the [ __ ] comments
and should be said yeah
and then two seconds later he's like hey
i'm like yeah i just no i can't read and
listen at the same time
it caused a time warp louie said i'll
pay if tom gets a legit perm
[ __ ] no man not getting some offense
they still sell those like perms like
tony or whatever that was the 70s i
think tio and i
wasn't like a tony the hand the hand you
know okay they don't perms don't work on
my tina if you like the hand you also
got to see the island
with my chain that's a florida story and
david warner is in it yeah david
warner's
pirates right kind of yeah what happens
is uh he go he's from new york and he
goes to florida
with his son and he's tricking his son
he told his son they were going to go to
disney world but when he gets there he's
an investigative reporter he's got to do
some other [ __ ]
and he's investigating the bermuda
triangle and so he gets down into the he
takes his son fishing in the bermuda
triangle and they get [ __ ] jacked by
some [ __ ] pirates
he wakes up in a damn pirate camp on
this [ __ ] pirate
island and it turns out he thought they
were role-playing that they were larping
in pirates that's the pirate larp i
thought it was a pirate larp
island turns out they were pirates
they had been there for like 400 years
they were getting all inbred they're
like inbred pirates
yeah they were running out of women and
[ __ ] it was [ __ ] bizarre that's a
weird movie it's [ __ ] good though
it's a real good movie they say the
books even better
well wouldn't it is didn't uh peter
benchley write that the same guy that
wrote jaws like the novel
i don't know i thought that i yeah i
maybe i'm remembering that wrong
yeah they were they had some covenant
there was some covenant with their
[ __ ] pirate leader
i don't remember which one it was and uh
they were trying to hold the tribe
together
and [ __ ] re-emerge back into the
world it's pretty pretty good
yeah pirates are going to take over the
water that's trying to take over the
world they would
they needed more breeding stock well
yeah obviously because there was like 30
of them or something
yeah well on the reason why they went to
go hide out there
they think there was more details in the
book somebody was telling me about it
they had pirates they had to hide for
some reason or another and they picked
that
that island to hide in this is like
hundreds of years ago
and uh they had captured a bunch of
hookers from the brothel
and they were gonna take them with them
and
uh so they had a small breeding
population but it wasn't big enough to
sustain them over a couple
right they're all gonna get like weird
genetics yeah yeah
yeah and it shows what year it was made
70s sometimes it was 70s i can't
remember that 78
i want to say but i could be totally
wrong about that but it was right around
that time maybe yeah maybe i'm totally
wrong
1980 fourth jordan says maybe yeah i
showed it to sophie she didn't know what
she was getting into what'd you think of
a sophie
it's a weird movie yeah it as a kid i
saw
it [ __ ] affected me they made a lot
of weird [ __ ] and they made a lot of
weird [ __ ] back in the 70s
they were gonna they they caught michael
kane and the only
one the one woman they had decided she
was gonna use him as breeding stock
so he was they so he was she was
carrying them around on a leash
trying to get pregnant because evidently
she couldn't get pregnant from the guys
that were on there they were all
starting to get kind of sterile
and uh it's a trip she's like these ones
are all shooting blanks
yeah we need some yeah
and they thought that he was uh his name
his last name was maynard so they
thought that he was the descendant of
some [ __ ] friendly pirate that they
they had revered maynard is a friendly
pirate yeah
the new children's book well yeah the
family pirate
know they thought that it was an allied
pirate right i mean he was the senate
and so they saw him as nobility they
didn't want to kill him
they were trying to get him to join it
it was it's [ __ ] cool story in a way
but then uh the the ending was pretty
cool sorry when i said friendly pirate
all i could think of was that
british uh was it a cartoon captain pug
wash
yeah i don't know she found it she said
she found her put it on
also the swarm yeah i like the swarm too
and dressed to kill we need to like do a
review on that one of these days
i should write it down and put it in my
box sophie said the accents were
hilarious you see
they had been on there for centuries and
um they're like their version their
english was very archaic it was mixed
with french too
and it kind of degenerated into a into a
new language it was
you can understand what they're saying
but you have to kind of yeah
pay close attention to what they're
saying sophie said maynard is the dude
that killed blackbeard in real life
yeah sure okay yeah all right yeah so
maybe that's why
so they thought that he was big magic
basically
yeah fourth throw down if you like the
hand you'd like that it's michael caine
during his i will do anything for money
period which i don't think ever really
ended did it no
no no michael caine during the interview
said that the most
that the main thing was is to make sure
that you got paid that you got paid up
front and that you had good hotel
a good hosting i respect that yeah
accommodations
and it's just a job yeah and that your
food was paid for at the hotel your food
your [ __ ] bar
[ __ ] tab was paid for that's real you
know
well a lot of actors didn't care what it
was yeah a lot of actors they're like oh
where are you shooting this movie it's
like
oh like this nice island or something
well [ __ ] yeah
yeah i'm going there so i can like go
lay on the beach that was his main
advice he made a whole training video on
how to become an
actor yeah that's right we watched parts
of it yeah yeah
yeah he's teaching you how to act and he
goes what you do is what you
you look in the camera and you look and
then you look and then you look
pretty much yeah i think personally when
you look at someone make sure you speak
and then you speak and you look and then
you speak
and then you look like okay that's how
you [ __ ] act mike that's what i mean
yeah i figured out i'm gonna get michael
i'm gonna get him down
okay all right you promised it i'm gonna
dress up for him as [ __ ] halloween
that's what i mean on the halloween show
now i gotta think of something
yeah who can i maybe i can be maybe i
can be the shark from jaws four
i'm gonna put on i'm gonna put on that
overall that he wore as a prisoner in
the hand
yeah there you go yeah oh it'd be
funnier if you were his
his character from the hand and then you
could just like have it look like a hand
guy kind of yeah i don't know how i'd
work that out
well you just have to have like a long
sleeve and then i have to put a drink
and [ __ ] on the show i didn't just be
for [ __ ] looking and pull my hand out
there it is
and then have a rubber hand
no need to get a rubber hand
everything's getting like really
complicated
yeah you're making the [ __ ] too
complicated
well i'm always i'm i really like
halloween so it's like i'm always kind
of like if you're gonna do the [ __ ] then
do the [ __ ] right you know what i'm
saying don't just like half-ass it
yeah all right so uh do you have
anything else you'd like to add
no i gotta get back to star wars he's
gotta get back to his star wars yeah i
gotta shoot [ __ ] down in space
i gotta go get some coffee and wake
myself back up because
every single morning i'm like oh i'm
gonna sleep in today and then i never do
yeah [ __ ] 6 30 i'm always awake it
sucks
all right so uh we will be back again
tomorrow
probably talking about another movie
because i think i got a couple that i
was planning on watching tonight so uh
thanks everybody for stopping by
and uh we'll see you guys again tomorrow
bye